‏of
the are
so
all of pleas
time and what can
the things that
days is let try not toல
the tr
ং
এ
carefulல
15 person
before you come for the eat pray and
need to have as
so distbute to the people so we have a
lot of respect request for the checks we
are processing those checks now so if
you theoney that will be much better for
us ان شاء الله جزاكم الله خيرا
[Arabic recitation]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
وصفيه من خلقه وخليله
وامينه على وحيه الداعي الى رضوانه ثم اما
بعد يقول الله تعالى في كتابه الكريم
ليدبروا
اياته
ويقول سبحانه وتعالى افلا يتدبرون القران
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ر
onder
meditate
ofر
‏is
we have the b so they will tells us they
willonder the book so they willonderes
who they who thisering to who are they
who are they
just say it speak
humanity the musls
is
‏Qu sch
noch
and that only are
the no
you see a sch you say hey you're suppos
to be doing
what about you well not a sch well then
youve got a lic to do whatever you like
right is that how that
[Silence]
صحيح مسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى عيسى عليه السلام
محمد عيسى عليه السلام
الله عيسى عليه السلام
اناجيلهم
في صدورهم
واعلمهم كتابا لا يغسله
‏The description is I going to give this
nation
a book that no amount of water will wash
away
and these men and these women will carry
their injil their b in their ch in their
hearts
and so
the qu's memoration
the schar
‏primary
numar
will have preserved
and whatever is
that is secondary
ر
med
toarn to understand
to
is a mir
only it is a mir that no am of lipck
‏ilteri
fromle
person up
find
her exact place
inر
and not where
رable
[Silence]
paper th ar being crumbled we to do what
‏clear conscience becauseilty consci
ruins all pleasures
and so the quran was never meant for
just the schar this is what happen with
the prev nation it was just for the
schar
and the schar of any particular nation
will only be as good as their stud and
‏more so even the teacher inspires the
student
and so
the qu
are into tyes and mention this because
there is a huge amount of confusion with
theران
شهce
[Silence]
‏and anyleil
and what happ we build this up mind we
going to be able to all that i don't
have time to buy and we avoid it all
that's not
‏inarifies
all other
is clear thatn'tlear
tole person
الله سبحانه وتعالى والهكم اله واحد
unar
[Silence]
الله شك
الله
هو الله احد قل اعوذ برب
الله لا اله الا هو
واقيموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه
ولا تقرب الزناز
انما الخمر والميسر والانصاب والازلام رجس
من عمل الشيطان
فاجتنبوه لعلكم تفلحون
محمد رسول اللهران
الله سبحانه وتعالى بل هو ايات بينات
في صدور الذين اوتوا
قران
cleares
in the ch of those
given knowledge
so to the schar all theران is clear
that takes years
come with exp they come
تقوى واتقوا الله ويعلمكم الله
[Silence]
عبد الله بن عباس
veryر
معاني القران على اربعه اوجهر
[Silence]
‏bir
little bir
feed
this is what do here feeding you
up youayن
عباسرes
وجه
لا يسع احدا جهله
[Silence]
حرام
الله
يقول ووجه
لا يعلمه الا العلماء
‏said and one tye only
meaning because of their knowledge of
the propet
are no matter how
gift you are no matter however you are
no matter how you are you need the
messenger toarify
يقول ووجه تعلمه العرب من كلامها
[Silence]
come
‏Isn't that different please come here?
These are the same thing asking for the
same thing.
‏if you are eng
between those sentوجه
الله
[Silence]
اعددت لعبادي الصالحين ما لا عين رات ولا
اذن سمعت ولا خطر على قلب بشر
صلى الله عليه وسلم ‏said, "I have
prepared for my slaves, my servants, a
place the likes of which no ey has ever
seen, no ear has ever heard the likes
of, and has never been imagined
even fleetingly by any human being."
‏parad
it go
are tyesanر
what
‏in any langage
translated what the second
the schar of reserve the knowledge of
because they mar the quران
number
the from their
‏people
think
of all haveil
to understand
right away at one go
and not only that but the audacity of it
is
‏this is not how knowled
the food ofs is poison for little bab
infant
you have
and you and you and youint
this is of knowledge the nature of our
exist ‏Can't just open the book under
your air conditioning
comfy in yourite pair of shorts right
snuggled up and just pop open the qu and
take a quick read and just I demand to
know everything right now what this mean
what that doesn't make any I don't know
about that I wonder I don't think people
have understood this the way supposed to
be understood mas
this
الله
عبد الله بن عبن
عباس
عمر بن الخطاب
entire
[Silence]
‏looking for one of number
not question and don't how to put into
words and they haven spent any timeing
that
and number
they
areandingw
اللهر
والراسخون في العلم ها يقولون
امنا به كل من عندي ربنا
[Silence]
peg into
their spice to go surfing the for answer
that will make them
‏and have anded
have00
of sweat and blood and tears to make
this book reach us in the way that it is
today. We don't have a right to with it.
‏with you have to no
to us
and so you
those
understand immedi
the type that understandable
‏As long as you understand and your
cognitive abilities are intact, you
should be able to understand it. Even if
you have a double digit IQ, you'll still
be able to understand it. ‏But there are
aspects that you have to learn an entire
language to see. There are aspects that
you have to learn thousands of
narrations and hundreds of years worth
of knowledge in to understand. ‏Don't
take
the contemplate is for you toate
not make what you want to always be
byر do not try toad it because we
saidday if you areyadر
it is actually what pushing
ر
[Silence]
نسال الله العافيه
من جعله بين يديه قاده الى الجنه ومن جعله
وراء ظهره ساق
الى النارell
[Silence]
والعياذ بالله
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يبارك لنا في
القران العظيم اساله تعالى ان ينفعني
واياكم بما فيه من الايات والذكر الحكيم
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
صلاه our تراويح
ان شاء الله تعالى
جزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
‏Just before we start our
বসি
পজি
আসসালামু আলাইকুম
as you know our long tradition from this
masjid is that we do not all outside
fundraising activities we do everything
ourselves here to serve the community
in place
‏are things add and those things with
you are other
do a job tove the muslম community at
large and that is one this is one of
those prs that i toare with you
they have a table outside and take a
moment to stop and learn about their
prrams and see if there is any assance
you can provide it is a saara pr and
‏This is a variety of things that they
do one of which is they provide the
health services educational prrams
helping the the espcially the vulnerable
ladies who may have fallen into a
situation where the family has been
broken and they need some help
to to get on their feet again. ‏So that
is a safe heaven prram that they have
and then of course there is a food
assistance and then there is a family
empowment prram so these are all the
prrams that they have there a table
outside pleas st by and you can learn
something about
and you can some pleas donate you canই
ان شاء الله ثانكس
استقيموا اعتدلوا استووا
سو الصف سدوا الخلل
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واذ قال ابراهيم لابيه وقومه انني براء
مما تعبدون
الا الذي فطرني فانه سيهدين
وجعلها كلمه باقيه في عقده لعلهم يرجعون
بل متعت
واباءهم
حتى جاءهم
الحق
الحق ورسول مبين
ولما
جاءهم
الحق قالوا هذا سحر
قالوا هذا سحر وانا به كافرون
وقالوا لولا نزل هذا القران على رجل على
رجل
وقالوا لولا نزل هذا القران على رجل من
القريتين عظيم
اهم يقسمون
رحمه ربك
نحن قسمنا بينهم معيشتهم في الحياه الدنيا
ورفعنا بعضهم فوق بعض درجات ليتخذ بعضهم
بعضا سخريا
ورحمه ربك خير مما يجمعون
ولولا ان يكون الناس امه
واحده
لجعلنا لمن يكفر بالرحمن لبيوتهم سقفا من
فضه من فضه ومعارج عليها يظهرون
ولبيوتهم ابوابا وسررا عليها يتكئون
وزخرفا
وان كل ذلك لما متاع الحياه الدنيا
والاخره عند ربك للمتقين
ومن يعش عن ذكر الرحمن نقيض له شيطانا فهو
له قرين
وانهم ليصدونهم عن السبيل ويحسبون انهم
مهتدون
حتى اذا جاءنا
قال يا ليت بيني وبينك بعد المشرقين
فبئس القريب
ولن ينفعكم
اليوم اذ ظلمتم انكم في العذاب مشتركون
افانت تسمع الصم
او تهدي
ومن كان في ضلال مبين
فاما نذهبن
بك فانا منهم منتقمون
او نرينك الذي وعدناهم
فانا
عليهم مقتدرون
فاستمسك بالذي اوحي اليك انك على صراط
مستقيم
وانه لذكر لك ولقومك وسوف تسالون
واسال من ارسلنا من قبلك من رسلنا اجعلنا
من دون الرحمن الهه
اجعلنا من دون الرحمن الهه يعبدون
ولقد ارسلنا موسى باياتنا الى فرعون
وملائه فقال
فقال اني
رسول رب العالمين
فلما جاءهم
باياتنا اذا هم منها يضحكون
وما نريهم من ايه الا هي اكبر من اختها
واخذناهم
بالعذاب لعلهم يرجعون
وقالوا يا ايها الساحر ادع لنا ربك بما
عهد عندك
ادع لنا ربك بما عهد عندك اننا لمهتدون
فلما كشف نا عنهم العذاب اذا هم ينكثون
ونادى فرعون في قومه قال يا قوم
قال يا قوم اليس لي ملك مصر وهذه الانهار
تجري من تحتيه
افلا تبصرون
ام انا خير من هذا الذي هو مهين
ولا يكاد يبين
فلولا القي عليه اسوره من ذهب
او جاء
معه الملائكه
مقترنين
فاستخف قومه فاطاعوه انهم كانوا قوما
فاسقين
فلما
اسفون انتقمنا منهم
فاغرقناهم
اجمعين
فجعلناهم
سلفا
ومثلا للاخرين
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولما ضرب ابن مريم مثلا اذا قومك منه
يصدون
وقالوا االهتنا خير ام هو ما ضربوه لك الا
جدلا بل هم قوم خصمون
ان هو الا عبد انعمنا عليه وجعلناه مثلا
لبني اسرائيل
ولو نشاء لجعلنا منكم ملائكه
في الارض
ملائكه
في الارض يخلفون
وانه
لعلم للساعه
فلا تمترن
بها واتبعون هذا صراط مستقيم
ولا يصدنكم
الشيطان انه لكم عدو مبين
ولما لما جاء عيسى بالبينات قال قد جئتكم
بالحكمه
قال قد جئتكم بالحكمه ولابين لكم بعض الذي
تختلفون فيه
فاتقوا الله واطيعون
ان الله هو ربي وربكم فاعبدوه
فاعبدوه هذا صراط مستقيم
فاختلف الاحزاب من بينهم
فويل للذين ظلموا من عذاب يوم اليم
هل ينظرون الا الساعه
هل ينظرون الا الساعه ان تاتيهم بغته وهم
لا يشعرون
الاخلاء
يومئذ بعضهم لبعض عدو الا المتقين
يا عبادي لا خوف عليكم اليوم ولا انتم
تحزنون
الذين امنوا باياتنا
وكانوا مسلمين
ادخلوا الجنه
انتم وازواجكم تحبرون
يطاف عليهم بصحاف من ذهب واكواب
وفيها ما تشتهيه الانفس وتلذ الاعين
وانتم
فيها خالدون
وتلك الجنه التي اورثتموها بما كن انتم
تعملون
لكم فيها فاكهه
كثيره
منها تاكلون
ان المجرمين في عذاب جهنم خالدون
لا يفتر عنهم وهم فيه مبلسون
وما ظلمناهم ولكن كانوا هم الظالمين
ونادوا يا مالك ليقض علينا ربك قال انكم
ماكثون
لقد جئناكم
بالحق ولكن اكثركم للحق كارهون
ام ابرموا امرا فانا مبرمون
ام يحسبون
انا لا نسمع سرهم ونجواهم
بلى ورسلنا لديهم يكتبون
قل ان كان للرحمن ولد فانا
قل ان كان للرحمن ولد فانا اول العابدين
سبحان رب السماوات والارض رب العرش عما
يصفون
فذرهم يخوضوا ويلعبوا حتى يلاقوا يومهم
الذي يوعدون
وهو الذي في السماء
اله وفي الارض اله
وهو الحكيم العليم
وتبارك الذي له ملك السماوات والارض
وما بينهما
وعنده علم الساعه
وعنده علم الساعه واليه ترجعون
ولا يملك الذين يدعون من دونه الشفاعه الا
من شهد بالحق
الا من شهد بالحق وهم يعلمون
ولئن ان سالتهم من خلقهم ليقولن الله
فانا
يؤثون
وقيله يا رب ان هؤلاء
يا رب ان هؤلاء
قوم لا يؤمنون
فاصفح عنهم وقل
فسوف يعلمون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
حميم
والكتاب المبين
انا انزلناه في ليله مبار
انا كنا منذرين
فيها يفرق فيها يفرق كل امر حكيم امرا من
عندنا انا كنا مرسلين
رحمه من ربك انه هو السميع العليم
رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما ان كن كنتم
مين
هو يحيي ويميت ربكم وربائكم
الاولين
بل هم في شك يلعبون
فارتقب يوم تاتي السماء
بدخان مبين
يغشى
الناس هذا عذاب اليم
ربنا اكشف عنا العذاب انا مؤمنون
اننا لهم الذكرى وقد جاءهم رسول مبين
ثم تولوا عنه وقالوا معلم
مجنون
انا كاشف العذاب قليلا انكم عائدون
يوم نبطش البطشه الكبرى انا منتقمون
ولقد فتنا قبلهم قوم فرعون وجاءهم رسول
كريم
ان ادوا الي عباد الله اني لكم رسول امين
وانا تعموا على الله
اني اتي
بسلطان مبين
واني عذت بربي وربكم ان ترجمون
وان لم تؤمنوا لي فاعتزلون
فدعى ربه ان هؤلاء
قوم مجرمون
فاسر بعبادي ليلا انكم متبعون
واترك البحر رهوا انهم جند مغرقون
كم تركوا من جنات
وعيون
وزروع
ومقام كريم
ونعمه كانوا فيها فاكهين
كذلك واورثناها
قوما اخرين
فما بكت عليهم السماء
والارض وما كانوا منظرين
ولقد نجينا بني اسرائيل من العذاب المهين
من فرعون انه كان عاليا من المسرفين
ولقد اخترناهم على علم على العالمين
واتيناهم
من الايات ما فيه بلاء
مبين
ان هؤلاء
ليقولون
ان هي الا موتتنا الاولى وما نحن بمنشرين
فاتوا بابائنا
ان كنتم صادقين
اهم خير ام قوم تبع
اهم خير ام قوم تدعوا والذين من قبلهم
اهلكناهم
انهم كانوا مجرمين
وما خلقنا السماوات والارض وما بينهما
لاعبين
ما خلقناهما الا بالحق
ولكن اكثرهم لا يعلمون
ان يوم الفصل ميقاتهم اجمعين
يوم لا يغني مولا عن مولا شيئا
ولا هم ينصرون
الا من رحم الله انه هو العزيز الرحيم
ان شجره الزقوم طعام الاثيم
كالمهل يغلي في البطون كغلي الحميم
خذوه فاعتلوه الى سواء
الجحيم
ثم صبوا فوق راسه من عذاب الحميم
زق انك انت العزيز الكريم
ان هذا ما كنتم به تمترون
ان المتقين في مقام امين
في جنات
وعيون
يلبسون من سندس
واستبرق
متقابلين
ذلك وزوجناهم
بحور عين
يدعون فيها بكل فاكهه امنين
لا يذوقون فيها الموت الا الموته الاولى
ووقم عذاب الجحيم
فضلا من ربك ذلك هو الفوز العظيم
فانما يس سرناه بلسانك لعلهم يتذكرون
فارتقب انهم
مرتقبون
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم حم
تنزيل الكتاب من الله العزيز الحكيم
ان في السماوات والارض لايات للمؤمنين
وفي خلقكم وما يبث من دابه
ايات لقوم ليوقنون
واختلاف الليل والنهار وما انزل الله من
السماء ماء
وما انزل الله من السماء
من رزق فاحيا به الارض بعد موتها
وتصريف الرياح ايات لقوم يعقلون
تلك ايات الله نتلوها عليك بالحق
فباي حديث بعد الله واياته
يؤمنون
ويل لكل اثاك اثيم
يسمع ايات الله تتلى عليه ثم يصر مستكبرا
كان لم يسمعها
فبشره بعذاب اليم
واذا علم من اياتنا شيئا اتخذها هزوا
اولئك
لهم عذاب مهين
من ورائهم جهنم ولا يغني عنهم ما كسبوا
شيئا ولا ما اتخذوا من دون الله اولياء
ولهم عذاب عظيم
هذا هدى والذين كفروا بايات ربهم لهم عذاب
من رجز اليم
الله الذي سخر لكم البحر لتجري الفلك فيه
بامره ولتبتغوه
ولتبتغوا من فضله ولعلكم تشكرون
وسخر لكم ما في السماوات وما في الارض
جميعا منه ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يتفكرون
قل للذين امنوا يغفروا للذين لا يرجون
ايام الله
ليجزي قوما بما كانوا يكسبون
من عمل صالحا فلنفسه ومن اساء فعليها
ثم
الى ربكم ترجعون
ولقد قد اتينا بني اسرائيل الكتاب والحكم
والنبوه
ورزقناهم
من الطيبات وفضلناهم على العالمين
واتيناهم
بينات
من الامر فما اختلفوا الا من بعد ما جاءهم
العلم بغيا بينهم
ان ربك يقضي بينهم يوم القيامه فيما كانوا
فيه يختلفون
ثم جعلناك على شريعه من الامر فاتبعها
فاتبعها ولا تتبع اهواء
الذين لا يعلمون
انهم لن يغنوا عنك من الله شيئا
وان الظالمين
بعضهم اولياء
بعض والله ولي المتقين
هذا بصائر للناس وهدى ورحمه لقوم يوقنون
ام حسب الذين اجترحوا السيئات ان نجعلهم
كالذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات سواء
محياه هم
سواء
محياه ومماتهم ساء ما يحكمون
وخلق الله السماوات والارض بالحق
ولتجزى كل نفس بما كسبت وهم لا يظلمون
افرايت من اتخذ الهه هواه واضله الله على
علم وختم على سمعه وقلبه
وجعل على بصره غشاوه
فمن يهديه من بعد الله افلا تذكرون
وقالوا
ما هي الا حياتنا الدنيا نموت ونحيا وما
يهلكنا الا لده وما لهم بذلك من علم ان هم
لا يظنون
واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا بينات ما كان
حجتهم
ما كان حجتهم الا ان قالوا ائتوا بابائنا
ان كنتم صادقين
قل الله يحييكم ثم يميتكم ثم يجمعكم الى
يوم القيامه لا ريب فيه
ولكن
اكثر الناس لا يعلمون
ولله ملك السماوات والارض ويوم تقوم
الساعه يومئذ يخسر المبطلون
وترى كل امه
جاثيه
كل امه تدعى الى كتابها
اليوم تجز زون ما كنتم تعملون
هذا كتابنا ينطق عليكم بالحق
انا كنا نستنسخ ما كنتم تعملون
فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فيدخلهم
ربهم في رحمته ذلك هو الفوز المبين
واما الذين كفروا افلم تكن اياتي تتلى
عليكم فاستكبرتم
فاستكبرتم وكنتم قوم مجرمين
واذا قيل ان وعد الله حق والساعه لا ريب
فيها
قلتم ما ندري ما الساعه ان نظن الا ظنا
وما نحن بمستيقنين
وبدى لهم سيئات ما عملوا وحاق بهم ما
كانوا به يستهزئون
وقيل اليوم ننساكم
كما نسيتم لقاء يومكم هذا وماواكم
النار وما لكم من ناصرين
ذلكم بانكم اتخذتم ايات الله هزوا
وغرتكم الحياه الدنيا
فاليوم لا يخرجون منها ولا هم يستعتبون
فلله الحمد رب السماوات ورب الارض رب
العالمين
وله الكبر
في السماوات والارض
وهو العزيز الحكيم
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
அலைக்கும்பil
‏take
some what need to beble to
the par are here with us so toqu you
take to the area and let them take care
of while you enjoy
recitation andavশ
again this is free
‏care
you
টো জাজাকল্লাহ
[Silence]
‏speci
تقرا
[Silence]
وعليكم السلام ورحمه
استووا
استووا واعتدلوا
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ح مموات
والارض وما بينهما الا بالحق واجل مسمى
والذين كفروا عما انذروا معرضون
قل ارايتم ما تدعون من دون الله
اروني ماذا خلقوا من الارض ام لهم شرك في
السماوات
ايتوني بكتاب من قبل هذا او اثاره من علم
ان كنتم صادقين
ومن اضل ممن يدعو من دون الله من لا
يستجيب له الى يوم القيامه وهم عن دعائهم
غافلون
واذا حشر الناس كانوا لهم اعداء
وكانوا بعبادتهم غافلين
وكانوا بعبادتهم كافرين
واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا بينات قال الذين
كفروا للحق لما جاءهم
هذا سحر مبين
ام يقولون افتراه
قل ان افترى ريته فلا تملكون لي من الله
شيئا هو اعلم بما تفيضون فيه
كفى به شهيدا بيني وبينكم وهو الغفور
الرحيم
قل ما كنت بدعا من الرسل وما ادري ما يفعل
بي ولا بكم ان اتبع الا ما يوحى الي وما
انا الا نذير مبين
قل ارايتم ان كان من عند الله وكفرتم به
وشهد شاهد من بني اسرائيل
على مثله فامن واستكبرتم
ان الله لا يهدي القوم الظالمين
وقال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا لو كان حقا
ما سبقونا اليه
وقال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا لو كان خيرا
واذ لم يهتدوا به فسيقولون هذا افك قديم
ومن قبله كتاب موسى اماما ورحمه
وهذا كتاب مصدق وهذا كتاب مصدق الرس هذا
كتاب مصدق لسانا عربيا لينذر الذين ظلموا
وبشرى للمسلم وبشرى للمحسنين
ان الذين قالوا ربنا ثم استقاموا فلا خوف
عليهم ولا هم يحزنون
اولئك
اصحاب الجنه اولئك اصحاب الجنه خالدين
فيها جزاء
بما كانوا يعملون
ووصينا الانسان بوالديه احسانا حملته امه
كرها ووضعته كرها وحمله وفصاله 30 شهرا
حتى اذا بلغ اشده وبلغ 40 سنه قال رب
اوزعني ان اشكر نعمتك التي انعمت علي وعلى
والدي
وان اعمل صالحا ترضاه
واصلح لي في ذريتي
اني تبت اليك واني من المسلمين
اولئك
الذين نتقبل عنهم احسن ما عملوا ونتجاوز
عن سيئاتهم في اصحاب الجنه
وعد الصدق الذي كانوا يوعدون
والذي قال لوالديه اف لكما اتعدانني ان
اخرج وقد خلت القرون من قبلي وهما
يستغيثان الله ويلك امن ان وعد الله حق
وهما يستغيثان الله ويلك امن ان وعد الله
حق فيقول ما هذا الا اساطير الاولين
اولئك الذين حق عليهم القول في امم قد خلت
من قبلهم من الجن والانس انهم كانوا
خاسرين
ولكل درجات مما عملوا وليوفيهم اعمالهم
وهم لا يظلمون
ويوم يعرض الذين كفروا على النار اذهبتم
طيباتكم في حياتكم الدنيا فاليوم تجزون
عذاب الهون بما كنتم بما كنتم تستكبرون في
الارض بغير الحق وبما كنتم تفسقون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واذكر اخا عاد اذ انذر قومه بالاحقاف وقد
خلت النذر من بين يديه ومن خلفه الا
تعبدوا الا الله
اني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم عظيم قالوا
اجئتنا لتافكنا عن الهتنا فاتنا بما تعدنا
ان كنت من الصادقين
قال انما العلم عند الله وابلغكم ما ارسلت
به ولكني اراكم قوما تجهلون
فلما راوه عارضا مستقبل اوديتهم قالوا هذا
عارض ممطرنا بل هو ما استعجلتم
به ريح فيها عذاب اليم
تدمر كل شيء بامر ربها فاصبحوا لا يرى الا
مساكنهم
كذلك نجزي القوم المجرمين
ولقد مكناهم في ماء مكناكم فيه وجعلنا لهم
سمعا وابصارا وافئده
فما اغنى عنهم سمعهم ولا ابصارهم ولا
افئدتهم من شيء اذ كانوا يجحدون بايات
الله
وحاق بهم ما كانوا به يستهزئون
ولقد اهلكنا ما حولكم من القرى وصرفنا
الايات لعلهم يرجعون
فلولا نصرهم الذين اتخذوا من دون الله
قربانا الهه بل ضلوا عنهم وذلك افقهم وما
كانوا يفترون
واذ صرفنا اليك نفرا من الجن يستمعون
القران
فلما حضروه قالوا انصتوا فلما قضي ولوا
الى قومهم منذرين
قالوا يا قومنا انا سمعنا كتابا انزل من
بعد موسى مصدقا لما بين يديه
يهدي الى الحق والى طريق مستقيم.
يا قومنا اجيبوا داعي الله
يا قومنا اجيبوا داعي الله وامنوا به يغفر
لكم من ذنوبكم ويجركم من عذاب اليم
ومن لا يجب داعي الله فليس بمعجز في الارض
وليس له من دونه اولياء
اولئك في ضلال مبين
اولم يروا ان الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض ولم يعي بخلقهن بقادر على ان يحيي
الموتى بلى انه على كل شيء قدير
بلى انه على كل شيء قدير
ويوم يعرض الذين كفروا على النار اليس هذا
بالحق قالوا بلى وربنا
قال فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم تكفرون
فاصبر كما صبر اولو العزم من الرسل ولا
تستعجل لهم كانهم يوم يرون ما يوعدون لم
يلبثوا الا ساعه من نهار
بلاغ
فهل يهلك الا القوم الفاسقون
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله اضل
اعمالهم والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وامنوا بما نزل وامنوا بما نزل على محمد
وهو الحق من ربهم كفر عنهم سيئاتهم واصلح
بالهم
ذلك بان الذين كفروا اتبعوا الباطل وان
الذين امنوا اتبعوا الحق من ربهم كذلك
يضرب الله للناس امثالهم
فاذا لقيتم الذين كفروا فضرب الرقاب حتى
اذا اثخنتموهم
فشدوا الوثاق
فاما اما منا بعد واما فداء حتى تضع الحرب
اوزارها
ذلك ولو يشاء الله لانتصر منهم ولكن ليبلو
بعضكم ببعض والذين قاتلوا في سبيل الله
فلن يضل اعمالهم
سيهديهم ويصلح بالهم ويدخلهم الجنه عرفها
لهم. يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تنصروا الله
ينصركم ويثبت اقدامكم
والذين كفروا فتعسا لهم واضل اعمالهم
ذلك بانهم كرهوا ما انزل الله فاحبط
اعمالهم
افلم يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف كان
عاقبه الذين من قبلهم دمر ر الله عليهم
وللكافرين امثالها
ذلك بان الله مولى الذين امنوا وان
الكافرين لا مولى لهم
اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعم انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار
والذين كفروا يتمتعون وياكلون كما تاكل
الانعام والنار مثواى لهم
وكاي من قريه اهل وكاي من قريه هي اشد قوه
من قريتك التي اخرجتك اهلكناها فلا ناصر
لهم
وكاي من قريه هي اشد قوه من قريه ك التي
اخرجتك اهلكناهم فلا ناصر لهم
افمن كان على بينه من ربه كمن زين له سوء
عمله واتبعوا اهواءهم
مثل الجنه التي وعد المتقون فيها انهار من
فيها انهار من ماء غير اسن وانهار من لبن
لم يتغير طعمه وانهار من خمر لذه للشاربين
وانهار من عسل مصفى
ولهم فيها من كل الثمرات ومغفره من ربهم
كمن هو خالد في النار وسقوا ماء حميما
فقطع امعاءهم
ومنهم من يستمع اليك حتى اذا خرجوا من
عندك قالوا للذين اوتوا العلم ماذا قال
انفا اولئك الذين طبع الله على قلوبهم
واتبعوا اهواءهم
والذين اهتدوا زادهم هدى واتاهم تقواهم
فهل ينظرون الا الساعه ان تاتيهم بغته فقد
جاء اشراطها
فانا لهم اذا جاءتهم
ذكراهم
فاعلم انه لا اله الا الله واستغ واغفر
لذنبك وللمؤمنين والمؤمنات
والله يعلم متقلبكم ومثواكم ويقول الذين
كفروا لولا نزل ولولا نزلت سوره ويقول
ويقول الذين امنوا لولا نزلت سوره فاذا
انزلت سوره محكمه وذكر فيها القتال
فاذا انزلت سوره
محكمه وذكر فيها القتال رايت الذين في
قلوبهم مرض ينظرون اليك
ينظرون اليك نظر المغشي عليه من الموت
فاولى لهم طاعه وقول معروف
فاذا عزم الامر فلو صدقوا الله لكان خيرا
لهم
فهل عسيتم ان وليتم ان تفسدوا في الارض
وتقطعوا ارحامكم
اولئك
الذي اولئك الذين لعنهم الله فاصمهم واعمى
ابصارهم
افلا يتدبرون القران ام على قلوب اقفالها
ان الذين ارتدوا على ادبارهم من بعد ما
تبين لهم الهدى الشيطان طان سول لهم واملى
لهم ذلك بانهم قالوا للذين كرهوا ما نزل
الله سنطيعكم في بعض الامر والله يعلم
اسرارهم
فكيف اذا توفتهم الملائكه
يضربون وجوههم وادبارهم
ذلك بانهم اتبعوا ما اسخط الله وكرهوا
رضوان وانه فاحبط اعمالهم
ام حسب الذين في قلوبهم مرض انن يخرج الله
اضغانهم
ولو نشاء لاريناكهم فلعرفتهم
بسيماهم
ولتعرفنهم
في لحن القول والله يعلم اعمالكم
ولنبلونكم
حتى نعلم المجاهدين منكم والصادقين ونبلو
اخباركم
ولنبلونكم
حتى نعلم المجاهدين منكم والصابرين ونبلو
اخباركم
ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله وشاقوا
الرسول من بعد ما تبين لهم الهدى لن يضروا
الله شيئا
لن يضروا الله شيئا
وسيحبط اعمالهم.
يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله واطيعوا
الرسول ولا تبطلوا اعمالكم
ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله ثم
ماتوا وهم كفار فلن يغفر الله لهم
فلا تهنوا وتدعوا الى السلم وانتم الاعلون
والله معكم ولن يتركم اعمالكم
انما الحياه الدنيا لعب ولهو وان تؤمنوا
وتتقوا يؤتكم اجوركم ولا يسالكم اموالكم
ان يسالكموها فيحفكم تبخلوا ويخرج اضغانكم
ها انتم هؤلاء
تدعون لتنفقوا في سبيل الله فمنكم من يبخل
فمنكم من يبخل ومن يبخل فانما يبخل عن
نفسه والله الغني وانتم الفقراء
وان تتولوا يستبدل قوما غيركم ثم لا
يكونوا امثالكم
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا فتحنا لك فتحا
مبينا ليغفر لك الله ما تقدم من ذنبك وما
تاخر ويتم نعمته عليك ويهديك صراطا
مستقيما
وينصرك الله نصرا عزيزا هو الذي انزل
السكينه في قلوب المؤمنين ليزدادوا ايمانا
مع ايمانهم
ولله جنود السماوات والارض وكان الله
عليما حكيما
ليدخل المؤمنين والمؤمنات جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها خالدين
فيها ويكفر عنهم سيئاتهم وكان ذلك عند
الله فوزا عظ عظيما
ويعذب المنافقين والمنافقات والمشركين
والمشركات الضانين
بالله ظن السوء
عليهم دائره
السوء وغضب الله عليهم ولعنهم ولعنهم واعد
لهم جهنم وساءت
مصيرا
ولله جنود السماوات والارض وكان الله
عزيزا حكيما انا ارسلناك شاهدا ومبشرا
ونذيرا لتؤمنوا بالله ورسوله وتعزروه
وتوقروه
وتوقروه وتسبحوه بكره واصيلا
ان الذين يبايعونك انما يبايعون الله
يد الله فوق ايديهم فمن نكث فانما ينكث
على نفسه
فمن نكث فانما ينكث على نفسه ومن اوفى بما
عاهد عليه الله فسيؤتيه اجرا عظيما
سيقول لك المخلفون من الاعراب شغلتنا
اموالنا واهلونا فاستغفر لنا يقولون
بالسنتهم ما ليس في قلوبهم
قل فمن يملك لكم من الله شيئا ان اراد بكم
ضرا او اراد بكم نفعا بل كان الله بما
تعملون خبيرا
بل ظننتم ان لن ينقلب الرسول والمؤمنون
الى اهليهم ابدا وزين زين ذلك في قلوبكم
وزين ذلك في قلوبكم وظننتم ظن السوء وكنتم
قوما بورا
ومن لم يؤمن بالله ورسوله فانا اعتدنا
للكافرين سعيرا
ولله ملك السماوات والارض يغفر لمن يشاء
ويعذب من يشاء
وكان الله غفورا رحيما
سيقول المخلفون اذا انطلقتم الى مغانم
لتاخذواها ذرونا نتبعكم
يريدون ان يبدلوا كلام الله
قل لن تتبعونا كذلك قال الله من قبل
فسيقولون بل تحسدوننا
بل كانوا يفقهون الا قليلا
قل للمخلفين من الاعراب ستدعون الى قوم
اولي باس شديد تقاتلونهم او يسلمون
فان تطيعوا يؤتكم الله اجرا حسنا وان
تتولوا كما توليتم من قبل يعذبكم عذابا
اليما
ليس على الاعمى حرج ولا على الاعرج حرج
ولا على المريض حرج ومن يطع الله ورسوله
يدخله جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار
ومن يتولى يعذبه عذابا اليما
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
make شفع وتر
‏back and back and
up
andate
صلاه
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والعصر ان الانسان
لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات وتواصوا
بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
انا
اعطيناك
الكوثر
فصل لربك وانحر
ان شانئك هو الابتر
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
ان لا اله الا
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا
شر ما قضيت
فانك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذ
واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
اللهم اننا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو امائك
نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل فينا
قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك
او انزلته
في كتابك او علمته
احدا من خلقك او استاثرت به في علم الغيب
عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جاهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسيناه
وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم اننا نسالك فعل
الخيرات
وترك المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت بعباد ك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير
مفتونين
اللهم اننا نسالك
نسالك موجبات رحمتك وعزائم
مغفرتك
والغنيمه من كل بر والسلامه من كل اثم
والفوز بالجنه
والنجاه
من النار
ربنا اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا
من النار
ربنا
رقابنا من النار
ربنا لا تدع لنا في هذا الجمع المبارك
ذنبا الا غفرته ولا دينا الا قضيته ولا
هما الا فرجته
ولا م ولا مريضا الا شافيته ولا مقطوعا
الا اوصلته
اللهم اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا
اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا
وكفر عنا سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع الابرار
ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا
ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه
انك لا تخلف الميعاد
ربنا
اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا
عذاب النار
وقنا عذاب النار
ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا وذرياتنا
قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين
اماما
ثبت قلوبنا على دينك يا مقلب القلوب ثبت
قلوبنا على دينك ويا مصرف القلوب صرف
قلوبنا الى طاعتك
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واخد الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفا الفاق والمنافقين
اللهم انصر اخواننا واخواتنا المجاهدين
في غزه وفلسطين
وفي السودان وفي كشمير
وحيث حلوا اللهم اجعلهم على عدوهم ظاهرين
لعدوهم راغمين
واجعل اجعل قتلا في الجنان
واجعل قتلا في الجنان
اللهم انزل على قلوبهم السكينه والسلوى
انزل في قلوبهم السكينه والسلوى والطمئنين
والانس
بك اللهم لا
انس الا
سك فانسنا وانس اخواننا المجاهدين
ربنا عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
اللهم اننا نتبتل اليك لما قتلتهم
لما دمرتهم
لما اخزيتهم
اللهم
اقتلهم قتل عاد وارم وزلزل اركانهم
وصدع بنيانهم
واقذف في قلوبهم الذل والهوان والصغار
واجعل قتلاهم في النار
واجعل احياءهم
في ذل وهوان
حيث حلوا يا رب العالمين
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
اكبر سبحان
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
س
انا ما بحبش
الله